[Musique]
cp il y a encore quelques jours dans les
ateliers de la compagnie française uta
au bourget les dernières finitions de
l'aérotrain orléans 250 80 250 km/heure
80 passagers construits en collaboration
ut ac cannes ce véhicule sur coussin
d'air qui est le premier aérotrain pense
que dans le monde
en vraie grandeur est destiné aux
liaisons intervilles à moyenne distance
il est caractérisé par un freinage
rapide et efficace réalisable au moyen
de ses patins un dispositif de rouve et
tractable et motrices permet aux
véhicules d'effectuer une translation
latéral encore plus caractéristique
cette élise caréné elle est d'un
diamètre de 2 mètres 30
elle est probablement la plus grande
église karine et au monde les essais de
l'aérotrain débuteront dès la fin de ce
mois sur la voie de 18 km de long
implanté au nord d'orléans
ce matin c'était la présentation aux
journalistes voici l'intérieur de
l'aérotrain veut dire que vous êtes le
tueur cameron
le producteur de ses terres autres
bientôt va être allé au cas où la
pression là vous êtes le poste de
commande
quelles sont vos impressions c'est
toujours les mêmes impressions que
peuvent avoir les équipages d'essai
quand ils prennent en main la première
fois la machine et
ce que nous espérons surtout maintenant
c'est pouvoir trouver les performances
que nous avons a lancé et pouvoir aller
à l'avant voir les très chics à deux
vitesses de concept et nous pensons
certainement attendre deviner sa vitesse
annoncée c'est à dire des croisières de
250 km heure a été poite de 300 km/heure
certainement assez rapidement pour la
première fois les lisent de l'aérotrain
à tourner monsieur bertin qui a conçu ce
titre sustentation partout synder nous
explique pour quelles raisons il s'est
orienté vers ce mode de transport
cette formule aérofreins a été voulu
offrir aux voyageurs père est un moyen
de transport en commun vraiment moderne
cette solution peut s'offrir aussi d'y
aller très grande vitesse pour les
voyages intervilles pour les liaisons
intervilles qu'une très grande souplesse
pour les liaisons en zone urbaine ou
suburbaines il est certain qu'à ce
moment là la vitesse n'a pas le même
facteur d'intérêt que pour les liaisons
intervilles
c'est un élément du problème on peut
dire aujourd'hui également qu'après plus
de dix ans de recherche
pas d'études et d'essais cette formule
est maintenant prête ou inexploités
[Musique]